STEVE: FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
BRIAN: PRESSURE MOUNTING ON
KAMALA HARRIS WHEN SHE WILL
ACTUALLY VISIT IF EVER THE
BORDER FOR A FIRSTHAND LOOK AT
THE CRISIS SHE IS SUPPOSED TO
FIX.
>> YOU HAVEN’T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN’T BEEN TO EUROPE.
I MEAN, I DON’T -- I DON’T
UNDERSTAND THE POINT THAT YOU
ARE MAKING.
>> I HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER
BEFORE.
I WILL GO AGAIN.
BUT WHEN I’M IN GUATEMALA.
[LAUGHTER]
DEALING WITH ROOT CAUSES, I
THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT’S GOING
ON IN GUATEMALA.
>> CAN YOU COMMIT RIGHT NOW THAT
YOU WILL INDEED VISIT THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER AND WILL YOU
DO IT SOON?
>> YES, I WILL.
AND I HAVE HAVE BEFORE.
BRIAN: WHY IS SHE LAUGHING?
HERE TO REACT PIN NELL COUNTY
SHERIFF MARK LAMB.
SHERIFF, DO YOU KNOW WHY SHE
WOULDN’T GO TO THE BORDER?
>> LOOK, WE’RE AS CONFUSED AS
OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS AFTER THAT
QUESTION.
LOOK, THIS IS OUR VICE PRESIDENT
WHO SAYS TO LESTER I DON’T EVEN
KNOW WHAT YOU ARE ASKING HERE.
LISTEN, KAMALA IF YOU DON’T KNOW
WHAT HE IS ASKING YOU ARE
DEFINITELY NOT THE RIGHT PERSON
FOR THE JOB.
SHE KEEPS PROVING TIME AND TIME
AGAIN WHY SHE IS NOT THE RIGHT
PERSON FOR THE JOB.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR
HER.
THAT’S WHY SHE IS NOT COMING
DOWN.
WE ARE LEFT TO BELIEVE THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT THIS CHAOS THAT IS
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY.
THAT’S WHY THEY REFUSE TO
ADDRESS IT AND HER IN
PARTICULAR.
IT’S NOT A LAUGHING MATTER.
SHAME ON HER.
BRIAN: PEOPLE FOCUS ON TEXAS.
IT’S TERRIBLE IN ARIZONA.
TALKED TO YOU ENOUGH TO KNOW
THAT YOU SEE THE EXACERBATION OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR THEY DON’T SEEM TO
CARE.
IS THE THEORY, SHERIFF, IF I SEE
IT I OWN IT?
IF I’M ACTUALLY SEEN AT THE
BORDER WITH THESE SOFT
FACILITIES WHICH ARE FILLED WITH
CHILDREN AND THESE -- AND THE
CHAOS OF OTHER CHILDREN BEING
DROPPED OVER THE WALL AND THE
BORDER PATROL ROUNDING UP
THOUSANDS IF SHE IS SEEN WITH
THIS SHE WILL ACTUALLY HAVE TO
OWN THIS.
>> RIGHT, BRIAN, SEEN WITH IT
HAVE TO OWN IT LIKE A LITTLE KID
IF THEY JUST IGNORE IT IT’S NOT
A PROBLEM.
IT IS A PROBLEM KAMALA.
I’M TELLING YOU IT’S A PROBLEM.
WE ALL KNOW IT AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNOW IT THEY ARE WISE TO
IT.
THEY KNOW THIS AND, YET, THEY
REFUSE TO ADDRESS IT SHE REFUSED
TO COME DOWN HERE.
YOU KNOW, AND THEY KEEP SAYING
THAT THEY’RE ADDRESSING THE ROOT
PROBLEMS DOWN IN PLACES LIKE
GUATEMALA.
I WOULD CONTEND, HEAVILY CONTEND
THAT THE ROOT CAUSE IS JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS AND THEIR
POLICIES.
THEIR FAILED POLICIES.
THAT’S WHAT THEY NEED TO FIX
FIRST AND FOREMOST.
THEN IF YOU WANT TO GO DOWN AND
FIX THE REST OF THE WORLD’S
PROBLEMS, DO SO.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF OUR OWN HERE.
LET’S START WITH THOSE.
BRIAN: SHERIFF, WHAT’S YOUR
RESPONSE WHEN SHE SAYS THIS IS
A -- THERE IS NO SHORT-TERM FIX?
THIS IS A LEARN PROBLEM.
EVERY DAY IS A FIVE ALARM FIRE
FOR YOU AND YOUR OTHER OFFICERS.
DON’T TELL ME I GOT TO WAIT A
DECADE TO FIX IT.
GOT A MILLION PEOPLE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
>> EXACTLY.
BUT IT IS A PROBLEM THAT HAS
EXISTED FOR A LONG TIME BUT WE
HAD A PRESIDENT OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS WHO WAS WORKING HARD
TO FIX THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
DOING WHAT HE NEEDED TO DO.
THE WALL WAS BEING BUILT.
WE WERE SEEING A REDUCTION IN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
DRUG TRAFFICKING.
ALTHOUGH THE DRUGS WERE
INCREASING IN AMOUNTS, THE
AMOUNT OF BUSTS WE HAD WERE
REDUCING OR AT LEAST STAYING THE
SAME.
SO THESE ARE SUCCESSES WE WERE
HAVING.
BUT NOW THESE POLICIES THEY HAVE
THEY ARE MAKING IT EVEN LONGER
GAIN.
AND AS LONG AS THEY REFUSE TO
SECURE THE BORDER AND SHUT IT
DOWN, SHE IS RIGHT.
THIS IS NEVER GOING TO GO AWAY
AND GOING TO TAKE FOREVER TO FIX
IT.
BRIAN: JUST KEEP IN MIND IF YOU
ARE WATCHING FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND NOT IN A BORDER CITY
OR BORDER STATE.
THE PROBLEM IS YOURS, TOO.
SO BECAUSE THEY ARE SHIPPING THE
ILLEGALS OUT OF THESE BORDER
AREAS AND INTO YOUR TOWN AND
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO TELL YOU.
THEY WILL JUST BE THERE.
THEY MIGHT BE FINE PEOPLE.
THAT’S JUST NOT THE WAY A
COUNTRY CAN EXIST AND THRIVE.
THAT’S NOT THE WAY THE
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM SHOULD BE
WORKING, IT’S NOT JUST
GUATEMALA.
GOT OVER 100 COUNTRIES COMING
THROUGH THE BORDER.
FROM AFRICA TO THE CARIBBEAN TO
ROMAINE I CAN’T.
SO, THIS IS A MESS.
AND I DON’T THINK SHE
ACCOMPLISHED ONE THING EXCEPT
FOR PLEDGING MORE OF OUR MONEY
TO COUNTRIES THAT DON’T DESERVE
IT.
SHERIFF, THANKS SO MUCH.